bonjour merci de nous avoir rejoints
sur l'actualité économique locale et on
commence avec les titres l'actualité de
cette semaine c'est bien sûr le
lancement des soldes d'été nous
découvrirons le premier jour à la outlet
des des clés sous bois la caisse
d'Assurance Maladie lance une campagne
de sensibilisation sur le recours
qu'entretien déclaré les accidents
causés par une tierce personne
permettrait des millions d'économies à
l'échelle du département Caroline et
Agathe de yvelinoise ont lancé une
marque de lingerie destinée aux femmes
atteintes d'un cancer du sein une
initiative récompensée par le Prix de
l'encouragement au Trophée National de
l'entrepreneuriat au féminin et puis
nous retrouvons dans l'entretien Sylvie
bonsoir vous êtes présidente
d'alternatives et Jean-François Leblanc
bonsoir vous êtes son vice-président
alors pardon alternative est née la
fusion entre vos deux associations
réagir et active on donne plus
d'explications dans l'entretien avant ça
on passe à l'actualité économique de la
semaine
ça y est les soldes d'été ont débuté
pendant 5 semaines les commerçants
proposeront leurs articles à prix brader
ils attendent beaucoup de cette période
nous sommes allés prendre le pouls à la
outlet one nation Paris l'occasion
également de tirer un premier bilan 6
mois après son ouverture des images de
jeunes en villemann
les soldes d'été ont débuté hier
beaucoup de clients attendaient avec
impatience cette période de bon prix je
pense que il y a des bonnes affaires à
terre moi j'attends quand il y a les
soldes pour acheter un sans ça je ne
peux pas
c'est mon budget être serré les enfants
tout ça dans ce magasin les soldes
représentent 25% du chiffre d'affaires
annuel les ventes devraient être
multipliées par 6 car dans cet outlet de
luxe se déclait sous bois on vend des
articles des collections passées les
soldes se cumulent donc à des promotions
jusqu'à moins 80% du prix initial on
débute beaucoup plus de quantité
d'articles qu'une boutique
traditionnelle oui bien souvent les
clients ont prévu un budget à ne pas
dépasser
100 euros 200 euros dans ce magasin pour
homme on espère multiplier les ventes
par 10 cette boutique a intégré one
nation à son ouverture en décembre
dernier pour le moment les objectifs de
vente ne sont pas atteints mais les
résultats restent satisfaisants ça monte
doucement le centre est très loin de son
potentiel maximum
faut s'armer un peu de patience certes
mais c'est très encourageant pour la
suite donc vraiment très positif même
constat dans ce magasin de sport Rémi
compte sur les soldes pour accroître la
renommée de sa marque la fin annoncée
des soldes en 2015 lui semble un moyen
de clarifier les prix pour les
consommateurs
c'est pas toujours très très simple à
comprendre et les sols les seuls
flottants boum repart en bonne opération
commerciale on refait des sols donc là
c'est un peu plus structuré on revient
l'ancien système mais bon chaque semaine
30 000 visiteurs full le sol de ce
centre commercial après 6 mois
d'existence one nation commence à se
faire connaître ce jour nous ne sommes
pas arrivés représente 90 boutiques à
outlet qui seront renforcés avec
l'ouverture des Galeries Lafayette à
partir de septembre il restera à ce
moment-là une vingtaine d'espaces
commerciaux à ouvrir pour renforcer nos
segments premium il espère finir la
commercialisation des derniers espaces à
la fin du premier semestre 2015
déclaré un accident causé par un tiers
un acte citoyen qui pourrait économiser
des millions d'euros dans le département
à la sécurité sociale et donc au
contribuable c'est le message que
souhaite passer la caisse d'Assurance
Maladie plus d'explications avec ce
sujet réalisé avec Pascal Joseph
un animal trop affectueux un court reçu
une baignoire qui vous tombe sur la tête
avec ses affiches humoristiques la
caisse d'assurance maladie des Yvelines
lance une vaste campagne de
communication sur le recours contre
tiers derrière cette formulation
complexe un constat simple bon nombre
d'accidents sont causés par une tierce
personne un accident de la route une
bousculade à l'école une morsure
d'animaux même si l'accident n'est pas
volontaire les soins devraient être
prises en charge par l'assurance du
responsable finalement la curé pourrait
dire ça change pas grand chose pour moi
pour moi dans les deux cas me faire
rembourser la seule chose c'est que
c'est l'argent public et il n'y a pas de
raison que ce soit sur l'argent public
que on paye ses soins alors que
normalement ça serait une compagnie
d'assurance ou un tiers qui devrait le
payer
l'enjeu est de taille en 2013
l'assurance maladie des Yvelines a pu
récupérer 18 millions d'euros au niveau
national le montant s'élève à un
milliard et l'on estime que seul un
tiers des cas sont déclarés en 2013 près
de 5000 accidents ont été officiellement
causés par un tiers responsable à 60%
des cas des accidents de la route car un
protocole facilite les échanges avec les
assurances
pour déclarer un cas trois options sont
possibles par mail sur le site ameli.fr
par courrier ou par téléphone au 36 46
des partenariats sont également mis en
place avec les instances médicales et
les forces de l'ordre donc nous venons
de travailler avec beaucoup
d'établissements du département parce
que les acteurs ont changé il faut
remobiliser à chaque fois pour qu'il
soit bien
conscient de l'importance et qui nous
avertit le plus rapidement possible des
affiches devraient être distribuées en
septembre dans les établissements
scolaires pour rappeler qu'être
responsable ne signifie pas être
coupable
ce lundi à la Chambre des Métiers et de
l'Artisanat pardon une réunion
permettait à la préfecture de présenter
aux dirigeants de TPE le nouveau pacte
de responsabilité même si cette réforme
va leur permettre d'alléger leur
fiscalité les 10 dirigeants restent
mesurés quant à la véritable efficacité
excusez moi Olivier Maniscalco
le pacte de responsabilité présenté aux
entrepreneurs yvelinois c'est lors d'une
réunion ce lundi à la Chambre des
métiers de l'artisanat de Versailles que
chef d'entreprise est représentant de
l'État à l'occasion d'échanger autour de
la nouvelle réforme qui s'appliquera de
la rentrée 2014 à la fin du mandat
présidentiel en 2017 baisse du coût du
travail crédit d'impôt pour les
entreprises ou simplification des
démarches fiscales a priori le pacte de
responsabilité à de quoi séduire les
entrepreneurs pourtant durant la réunion
le ton monte rapidement
ça n'est pas
vous augmentez la TVA vous augmentez les
impôts vous augmentez non quel aide non
c'est nous qui payons des entrepreneurs
mécontents devant un nouveau changement
de fiscalité trop fréquent selon eux il
faut dire que pour un chef d'entreprise
difficile de prévoir sur le long terme
quand on ne sait pas ce dont la
fiscalité de demain sera faite j'ai fait
des travaux d'agrandissement dans mon
dans mon entreprise
nous on a pris un crédit sur 10 ans on
ne peut pas gérer sur deux ans si on
veut avancer si on vit au jour le jour
dans ce cas là on n'a pas de projet
c'est à dire qu'on ne fait pas de
recrutement on ne se projette pas dans
l'avenir autre problème abordé le
financement de ce pacte de
responsabilité certes aujourd'hui l'État
accorde un crédit d'impôts d'entreprise
mais les investisseurs s'attendent à un
retour de bâton prochainement on met en
avant des 30 milliards d'euros 40
milliards d'euros cet argent n'est pas
dans les caisses de l'État donc la
répartition va-t-elle profiter plus à
nous artisans on est dans la spectative
du côté de la préfecture qui présentait
cette réforme aujourd'hui on comprend
l'inquiétude de ses chefs d'entreprise
tout en se voulant rassurant la crise
est difficile donc il est normal mais si
vous écoutez bien vous verrez que telle
entrepreneur grâce au cice roi recruter
un apprenti de plus que tel autre aura
bénéficié d'une mesure et on aura
investi sur une nouvelle machine c'est
ça qui est important selon les
prévisions du gouvernement le pacte de
responsabilité devrait d'ici 2017
permettre la création 290 000 emplois en
France
un forum d'information sur la vente
directe à domicile se tenait aujourd'hui
à Élancourt un événement organisé par
l'Espace Emploi jusqu'à 20h il
permettait de présenter au public des
professionnels du secteur un public qui
comprend aussi bien des demandeurs
d'emploi que des retraités ou encore des
personnes qui cherchent un complément de
revenus l'occasion idéale de rencontrer
et de séduire un employeur en vue d'une
éventuelle embauche Olivier manuscalquo
et Patrick Jacques de Dixmude
comment se passe l'échange on commence
d'abord par découvrir la personne qu'on
est en face de soi et voir quelles sont
ses aspirations on est qu'au début du
salon mais j'ai déjà rencontré trois
personnes dont une me paraît très
intéressé par notre secteur d'activité
je voulais en fait savoir je suis
esthéticienne pour le moment où Pôle
emploi je me suis déplacé tout ça
simplement pour ça je trouve que c'est
une excellente idée
je découvre par exemple l'histoire
d'astellia c'est excellent
en tout cas
nous avions parlé dans cette émission
des concours Talents des cités et
talents de la création d'entreprise les
résultats pour la région sont tombés et
parmi les 8 lauréats figures un
yvelinois ils étaient près de 220 au
départ cette entrepreneur suivi par la
BGE du département et Christophe Vallet
il remporte avec son associé à Arnaud
Lecornu le prix jeune pousse leur site
programme Radio.com propose à l'instar
des programmes télévisuels toute la
programmation des radios une mine
d'informations c'est maintenant l'heure
de l'entretien
et pour cet entretien justement nous
recevons Sylvie veille bonsoir et
Jean-Christophe et Jean parlent
Jean-François Leblanc je vous change de
prénom alors vous êtes respectivement
président et vice-président
d’alternative cette association il a
fusion de vos deux associations
réagir et actives alors avant
d'expliquer pourquoi finalement ce
regroupement est-ce que vous pouvez nous
expliquer ce qu'est une association
intermédiaire s'il vous plaît une
association intermédiaire
accompagne les demandeurs d'emploi en
difficulté
personne au RSA personne plus d'un an de
chômage personne de plus de 50 ans
et les inscrits dans un parcours
d'insertion ils deviennent ils
deviennent salariés en parcours et le
principal outil
pour les soutenir c'est de la mise à
disposition c'est à dire que on met ces
personnes disposition des particuliers
des entreprises collectivités locales
pour leur procurer un revenu du travail
et mesurer
leur capacité aussi pour sortir de
l'association c'est l'objectif dans le
marché classique alors finalement quels
sont vos activités principales nos
activités les missions qu'on leur confie
exactement on va chercher tout ce qui
peut être réalisé par des personnes qui
sont assez bas niveau de qualification
en général enfin en tout cas c'est le
plus fréquemment ce cas là et puis des
missions qu'on peut accompagner c'est à
dire sur lesquels on va pouvoir doser la
progressivité de la réinsertion et puis
en fait l'idéal c'est que la personne
soit au bout de son parcours qui dure en
moyenne 18 mois deux ans sans capacité
de prendre un poste correspondant à si
éventuellement à la une formation
initiale ou alors un complément de
formation qu'on lui a procuré
généralement de l'aide à domicile
jardinage du jardinage du
débroussaillage ça peut être aussi de la
manutention ça peut être aussi dans le
secteur du bâtiment des travaux publics
du terrassement ou de l'aide à la
construction
quelquefois ils ont des talents qui se
révèlent sur le terrain donc on essaie
de décortiquer ça et de les découvrir
alors finalement pourquoi avoir décidé
de fusionner
alors pourquoi on a décidé de fusionner
bon c'était quelque chose qu'on évoquait
ça peut sous forme de boutade depuis
quelques années comme ça mais c'était
pas très sérieux à l'époque mais c'est
vrai que Jean-François Leblanc vous
expliquera pour quelle raison lui il a
pris la décision nous
active
on sentait bien que notre association
après les coups durs il y a eu des
séries de d'épisodes difficiles active
résultats déjà d'une fusion et que pris
de plein fouet la chute des heures chez
les particuliers puisque en 2008-2009 il
y a eu une émergence des des boîtes
privées qui ont commencé à proposer ces
services là effectivement quand nous on
proposait des personnes qui sont en
insertion pour faire ce travail
les clients préférés quelqu'un qui a
déjà la formation l'aisance etc donc il
y a eu moins de clients puis il a tué la
crise que tout le monde connaît et qui
n'a fait qu'aggraver les choses
les particuliers ont eu moins besoin en
tout cas les moins les moyens de
s'offrir trois heures de tonte de
pelouse alors qu'ils pouvaient le faire
c'est assez logique et donc petit à
petit
bon je passerai sur d'autres difficultés
de gestion qu'a connu l'association mais
quand je suis arrivée on était déjà en
perte de vitesse très importante et puis
on était en dessous du seuil de
d'équilibre d'une petite association
intermédiaire donc c'est vrai que c'est
une question qu'on se posait déjà depuis
au moins un an donc ça regroupé pour
être plus fort c'est un peu même constat
et réagir
réagir
il y a une raison aussi toute
personnelle bon c'est pas laisser pas
l'essentiel mais ça fait 20 ans que j'ai
créé cette association et depuis un
petit moment je cherchais quelqu'un pour
prendre le relais je vais un petit peu
de mal quand on a rencontré Sylvie on
s'est dit peut-être qu'il y a quelque
chose à faire ensemble mais c'est pas
l'essentiel voilà ceci dit voilà le fond
robot finalement sur un problème aussi
financier je crois que vous aviez aussi
du mal à vous faire payer c'est ça
un petit peu comme actif avec des
problèmes financiers bon un redressement
quand même depuis deux ans deux ans et
demi pour ce qu'on a mis l'accent sur le
développement voilà en bougeant une
personne pour faire du développement
et on s'est aperçu en discutant ensemble
qu'on était très complémentaire
active amène surtout un modèle de
fonctionnement qui va être pris une
gouvernance aussi puisque la directrice
active à devenir directrice de
l'ensemble et puis Sylvie va prendre le
relais voilà
de personnel tout à fait et réagir même
un bon paquet d'heures disons de
fonctionnement pour un petit peu pour
l'équilibre économique donc à travers
ces quelques éléments on a pensé que
fusionner ne pouvait être intéressant
au niveau du personnel du coup il y aura
un poste en moins qui finalement quand
vous partirez à la retraite
puisqu'il y aura un directeur commun
le président les présidents sont
bénévoles donc on cherche aussi à faire
des économies sur la masse salariale des
salariés permanents et donc et là ça ne
pourra pas garder tout le personnel même
si c'est le principe de base
on peut pas avoir de directeurs c'est
pas possible dans une petite structure
comme la nôtre donc voilà on a trouvé le
directeur de mesure a choisi de
s'orienter vers une autre orientation
professionnelle donc voilà
alors finalement ça va aussi permettre
d'accroître le territoire sur lequel
vous êtes actif
on va prendre maintenant quasiment sous
notre regard très intéressé tout le sud
des Yvelines depuis 50 ans la Communauté
de Communes jusque jusqu'en dessous de
Rambouillet alors c'est un bien et un
souci c'est à dire que pour être partout
sur tout le territoire c'est quand même
assez compliqué quand on a 9 salariés
donc on va faire l'effort déjà de garder
ouvert tous les sites où on est déjà en
place et donc on aura le siège à
Saint-Cyr
une antenne qui sera ouverte en
permanence à la verrière c'est
l'actuelle siège de d'active mais qui
deviendra donc une antenne de
d'alternatives et puis les deux sites où
nous avons déjà des temps partiels c'est
Rambouillet aiguillancourt et nous
serons aussi donc dans ces deux communes
là après c'est le démarchage commercial
qui va faire que la notoriété va se
renouer partout et ça fait beaucoup de
communes quand même sans commune
alors pour le moment combien de
personnes accompagnez vous
en ce qui nous concerne on fait
travailler 220 230 personnes par an
enfin travailler pas tout à plein temps
et puis
180 un peu plus de 180 personnes sont
réellement accompagnées par des
conseillers en insertion professionnelle
les deux associations ensemble
on va voir le volume de deux postes et
demi
consacré uniquement à l'accompagnement
et c'est la grosse différence on nous
confond parfois avec l'intérim de la
grosse différence c'est l'accompagnement
chez nous voilà les personnes
ont des référents et qui vont pouvoir
les suivre donc ça c'est vraiment
essentiel de votre côté un petit peu
moins de personnes suivies
actuellement mais c'est vrai que de
pouvoir leur consacrer dans le cadre de
la démarche qualité un certain nombre
d'heures d'entretiens régulièrement pour
savoir où ils en pour essayer de les
aider à s'orienter mieux à choisir
effectivement les activités qui leur
conviennent et puis petit à petit de les
aider à progresser parce que il suffit
pas de leur faire
procurer du travail il faut aussi qu'à
terme ça évolue et bien c'est quand même
cette caractéristique là qui fait que on
apporte un plus hautement d'emploi et on
n'est pas on n'est pas Pôle Emploi on
n'est pas on n'est pas les assistants
sociaux on n'est pas une boîte d'intérim
on est une association intermédiaire et
ça c'est vraiment un concept qui est
très fragilisé par plein plein de
phénomènes économiques en ce moment mais
qui dans le cadre de l'ESS devrait
affirmer sa place voilà ce qui nous
paraît vraiment très important on
l'espère en tout cas pour renouveler les
modèles parce que les petites
associations de plus en plus de mal à
vivre il y en a une qui a fermé dans les
Yvelines cette année c'est assez rare
mais voilà on espère que cette vidéo
suffisamment solide avec quelque chose
comme 65 000 heures de travail
qui sera fourni par alternative sur un
an voilà le travail rémunéré on prendra
du coup dans les prochains mois merci à
tous les deux d'avoir été présent sur
notre plateau on passe tout de suite au
dossier la semaine
le concours national de
l'entrepreneuriat au féminin récompenser
la semaine dernière des femmes chefs
d'entreprise parmi elles à la Caroline
et Agathe de yvelinoise qui ont lancé
leur marque de lingerie destinée aux
femmes atteintes d'un cancer du sein une
création d'entreprise 100% féminine et à
destination des femmes nous sommes allés
les rencontrer à Chevreuse des images de
Jonathan Willmann et Sébastien combe
Caroline et Agathe de femmes deux amis
mais aussi de chefs d'entreprise
ensemble elles ont créé une ligne de
lingerie leur particularité s'adapter
aux contraintes des femmes atteintes
d'un cancer du sein un projet qui
découle de l'histoire personnelle de
Caroline à l'âge de 43 ans j'ai eu un
cancer du sein et suite à voilà à
plusieurs opérations j'ai rencontré de
grosses difficultés pour trouver de la
lingerie confortable et en plus joli
sexy sympa donc je me disais c'est pas
possible que personne n'est pensé à
faire quelque chose de joli de
confortable et qui soit particulièrement
adressée à ces femmes là agathe est
modéliste c'est elle qui a dessiné les
sous-vêtements pour chacun d'entre eux
il a fallu mêler conforts et esthétisme
le modèle Caroline s'adresse aux femmes
qui ont subi une ablation et une
reconstruction du sein on a travaillé
avec un industrie à Lyonnais et on a
fait breveté un cache armature qui se
trouve ici
qui est enduit de silicone à l'intérieur
donc on a un contact avec la peau qui
est très souple autre particularité les
armatures on a la possibilité d'avoir
une armature rigide qui énergétique et
classique d'une armature qu'on trouve
partout et une armature une armature à
titane à la mémoire de forme qui est
beaucoup plus souple et qui évite la
contrainte sur la cicatrice pour
l'intérieur des bonnets le choix s'est
porté sur une matière douce une doublure
de Tulle en aloe vera pour le reste du
temps sel et à chaque modèle on garde
une pointe de féminité c'est pour ça
qu'on a mis des petits anneaux ici ils
sont en plaqué or sur le noir sur le
blanc et son placard jaune pour donner
un petit côté un peu raffiné nos modèles
Caroline et Agathe ont toutes deux
découvert l'entrepreneuriat en se
lançant dans cette aventure pour les
accompagner dans leur reprise d'activité
elles ont fait appel à la Chambre de
commerce et d'industrie des Yvelines
notre entreprise à deux ans on est
toujours suivi encore pendant un an
pendant les trois premières années de
l'entreprise donc on a des
régulier là c'est maintenant mais c'est
vrai que le tout début c'était le
travail sur le business plan sur un peu
l'étude marketing donc nous on avait
fait en amont déjà notre enquête auprès
des femmes concernées donc on avait déjà
un petit bagage quand on est arrivé mais
c'est vrai que sur en plus le statut de
la société on savait pas lequel adopté
etc donc là ça nous a bien bien cadré en
fait voilà leur investissement s'élève à
48 000 euros donc 15000 proviennent d'un
prêt d'honneur à taux zéro réservé aux
demandeurs d'emploi le pénacre les
produits ont été fabriqués dans une
usine française en octobre dernier
doucement elle commence à se faire
connaître et ont reçu la semaine
dernière le trophée de l'encouragement
au concours national de
l'entrepreneuriat au féminin
on espère vraiment que ça nous ouvre des
portes côté entreprises et côté
clientèle déjà elle s'appelle un
troisième modèle qui portera le nom
d'Agathe le prochain sera vraiment dédié
à celle qui ont subi une mastectomie
donc on va proposer un soutien-gorge à
poche où on pourra mettre une prothèse
externe à l'intérieur cette idée leur
vient du terrain dans cette orthopédie
on regrette que l'offre actuelle se
limite à des modèles médicaux qui
occulte l'esthétisme les trois
fabricants essentiels enfin surtout deux
sont allemands et avec des goûts
allemands et c'est pas évident tout le
temps et c'est vrai que dans notre
clientèle les femmes par exemple quand
elles font un bonnet à ont pas besoin
d'un soutien-gorge qui soit hyper
emboîtant avec des grosses bretelles ils
ont un peu du mal à comprendre donc
c'était pour pouvoir offrir voilà un
modèle fabriqué en France avec un peu
plus sexy dans des bonnets A et B
concernant leurs deux premiers modèles
elles ont vendu 30% de leur production
soit près de 300 articles un chiffre
encore modeste car les prix des
sous-vêtements sont de 60 à 150 euros
mais les créatrices annoncent une baisse
de 20% à la rentrée prochaine grâce à
des réductions de coûts sur la
production la marque est aujourd'hui
distribuée dans une dizaine de points de
vente
orthopédiques comme ici magasin
spécialisé pour les femmes atteintes
d'un cancer du sein mais aussi sur
Internet on n'est pas encore très connu
dans les boutiques on a quelques
quelques bons retours mais c'est encore
un petit peu poussif alors effectivement
sur internet ça nous permet d'être vu
sur le plan national voire même
international parce qu'on a fait
quelques petites ventes en Suisse en
Belgique voilà donc ça permet
effectivement de visibilité plus
importante mais l'objectif reste de
rentrer sur le marché de la lingerie
classique de quoi toucher également une
clientèle plus large ce qui nous
plairait vraiment c'est d'avoir
notre marque parmi les jolies marques de
lingerie ce que moi je portais avant et
pouvoir voilà à être même si je peux
plus remettre ces anciennes marques au
moins me sentir dans cet univers peu
dentelle de lingerie très féminin un
moyen pour les femmes qui ont vaincu le
cancer de retourner dans des magasins de
lingerie classique et de ne plus se
sentir malade
la Chambre de commerce et d'industrie
des Yvelines organisons dernier Smart d
sur les objets connectés le 2 juillet
une journée de rencontre de 9h30 à 17h
sur le stand de la chambre au solar
Décathlon plus de 80 entreprises seront
présentes vous pouvez vous inscrire via
le site internet qui s'affiche et ce
stand de 100m² restera ouvert au public
jusqu'au 4 juillet et puis la CGPME
lance un nouvel événement mensuel allait
jeudi de l'excellence ce premier petit
déjeuner aura lieu à Rambouillet dans
leur Loco à 8h45 à chaque rendez-vous un
spécialiste dans son domaine vous fera
profiter de son retour d'expérience et
c'est la fin de ce fil écho merci de
nous avoir été fidèles rendez-vous la
semaine prochaine très bonne soirée